[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mark sanchez joins us on behalf of a
sleep number the leader in sleep health
as we know
of course my sleep number setting is uh
it's jumped up to 100 by the way
uh a month-long program with nfl legends
a sleep 30 challenge he'll talk about
that
coming up here in a moment mark good to
talk to you again
what's your favorite pete carroll story
dan p how we doing man good uh
let's see well before pete carroll 6-2
and a little change
probably 2 35 don't judge me wow
wow don't judge me okay i'm getting
older i'm getting a lot of sleep i'm not
quite as active oh
man pete carroll i think there's two
really good ones one was in the rose
bowl
the other one was the night before that
press conference that infamous press
conference
that uh made it look like him and i
hated each other
um which wasn't the case little did
people know the night before that press
conference we're
in my apartment uh on ellendale next to
usc's campus
uh let's see shoot apartment 313
baby and we were eating in and out
burgers
uh till like two three in the morning
just talking
about everything and he knew that i had
pretty much decided to leave
and he was still recruiting like hell to
keep me there
and uh so that was a that was a night
where i didn't get my full night's rest
and sleep number wouldn't be thrilled
about that
okay but then you had the press
conference so why did that happen
if you guys had already talked this out
the night before so
i think here's now that i can you know
look back in hindsight and
retrospect and all that he he didn't say
anything like
i don't like him i don't think um
he's a good player you know we're we're
not happy for him we don't want him to
do well he never said anything like that
but as far as those meeting or uh press
conferences have gone
to that point it was always
you know johnny's leaving for the nfl
well man whatever nfl team gets johnny
good for them he's awesome we love him
and we wish him the best
now pete eventually said nice things
like that but the first thing he said
was
and he said it the night before i don't
agree with the decision
okay which is fine he can have his own
opinion and we said that to each other
the night before i said coach no hard
feelings i get it
i just this is where i'm at here's what
i want to do cool and he's like well you
got to look at the statistics
you know rookie quarterbacks blah blah
when they come out early and he did all
his research
credit to him he knew exactly what he
was talking about so he gave an opinion
on my decision and then backed it up
with a bunch of nice
fluffy stuff which is fine but everybody
focused on that opinion and because he
gave that
those data points saying you know rookie
quarterbacks who leave early they don't
do this they don't do that blah blah
blah well that was
that was all fine too but nobody was
used to hearing that
so once they heard it they're like oh
dude he hates him
oh these guys don't like each other what
a jerk you know and
it wasn't really like that it was just
hey this is his opinion here's why he
thinks that
and it's all good do you think you could
have been
more successful or a more sustainable
career if you
had lower expectations you were going to
a team that was
playoff ready championship ready whereas
zach wilson is going to a jets team that
we don't have great expectations
so put yourself in in that position with
zach
and how how beneficial can that be uh
to his development or maybe even
detrimental
uh you know i think there's there's two
ways to go on this right
you nailed it i went into a team that
picked that was picking 15 or 16 overall
which means
you're middle of the pack they just
missed the playoffs with brett favre
and you know one bicep tendon like this
guy was hanging on for dear life
i just golf with him about a month and a
half ago and he told a bunch of those
stories which were incredible by the way
but so that's where that team was they
had great veteran leadership
we needed a couple receivers we ended up
getting braylon edwards santonio holmes
um and they had a tight end they had a
running back we drafted a running back
in sean green so this is a team that was
built to win
immediately and we were so good on
defense they won in spite of me multiple
times my rookie year like i have no
shame in admitting that
i threw five picks against buffalo and
we we took the game to overtime and we
rest for like 200 some yards
like that doesn't happen right so i went
to a place where they expected to win
immediately now i loved it but it also
set the bar
really high there was only one way to go
when you get to the afc championship
game
your first two years there's only one
way to go really two ways but one's a
lot easier
straight down right so either you go to
the super bowl and compete in the super
bowl
and win or lose whatever or you don't
make that game and now you're not as
good
and you know this new york media it's
very sensationalized it's best
or worse a very superlative so
that's just kind of the way it went now
if you go in
to that market maybe with less
expectations
sure that's fine i understand that
argument let the guy sit let
him learn let him you know have a solid
veteran ahead of them and
and kind of groom him the patrick
mahomes alex smith idea
great but you don't have that time in
new york
right all these guys that they have
there
it's like it's like the little league
team that stays together for like five
years
right and then by the time they hit high
school they don't even have to give like
pick off signs anymore they just know by
body language like boom we know what to
do
i know when it's you know when we're
thinking about bunting i know when to
drag on i know when to steal i know
all this stuff because we've done it for
so long you think the new york media is
going to give them that kind of time
no i mean they have a lot of young guys
and i hope they do i hope they keep
expectations realistic but i mean that's
just a tall task there so
uh you know the most important thing for
them is just little victories along the
way
block out the media as best you can let
that thing marinate and i think
i think if anybody's got a shot to do it
it's zach wilson i really like him
i liked him coming out in the draft
process he's got a couple things to
clean up i would think
in the pocket just every once in a while
there's a routine play that i'd like him
to just keep it routine right i don't
need
you know the the sports center highlight
uh every single
drop back right but when it's time you
know when to flip that switch
and be zack wilson and show us that
amazing play when it's fourth down when
you got to scramble when it you know the
game's on the line
but when it's just a wide open you know
easy grounder to second base just throw
the guy out at first and i think his
quarterback coach greg knapp
is gonna really really help with that
because he's been with some of the best
in the league with peyton manning some
of the best technicians that that know
how to keep the game
simple when it's supposed to be simple
and then when it's time to like i said
when it's time to
you know to go off and and do something
special and show me
who zach wilson is you'll know exactly
when that is and you'll flip the switch
and do it
he's mark sanchez the former nfl
quarterback how do you explain tom brady
then
brady told me many many years ago if he
had been drafted in the first round
he probably wouldn't have made it so
he's the greatest quarterback of all
time who might not have made it now that
he might be being humble but i think he
said i wasn't ready
and they would have asked me to be ready
as a first-round quarterback
sure and i think one of the biggest
things for tom brady
is the amount of sleep he gets he even
preaches that dan
okay sleep i mean he's got to be on a
sleep number that guy's got energy for
days so
um i just wanted to throw that in there
real quick but uh
there's just a lot of expectation when
it comes to that first pick overall
there's
there's so much expected of you that
um you know you're you're regardless of
your circumstances you're expected to do
well and and here's a great example
when i'm at sam darnold's pro day and uh
he's coming out of usc
and they're like i don't know he might
go to cleveland he might go here he
might go there
we're hoping he goes to the jets like
you like that would be so cool you know
usc to the jets and i'm talking with his
parents and all that
and i'm like yeah i mean listen i love
my time in new york don't take this the
wrong way
i'm like but the jets are just not very
good right now neither is cleveland at
the time
but i'm like either way like if you're
going in that top five
unless somebody trades into the top five
like the jets did for me
expectations should not be here like
you're drafting that early for a reason
so for tom i think he got to fly under
the radar he got to learn under drew
blood so he got to
um make a bunch of mistakes in practice
that nobody ever saw
maybe internally they corrected
obviously but
he got to run through situation after
situation after situation against one of
the best defenses
perennially all the time right before he
even got out on the field and that is
uh invaluable when it comes to grooming
a quarterback you want reps
you want reps in real situations not
seven on seven
or seven on you know air you know
passing lines and warm-ups
those don't count like once you get to
that level come on dude that's just
expected you're in a short spirit a pair
of shorts and t-shirt and maybe a helmet
like the ball shouldn't touch the ground
that's just the way it goes that's just
where we're starting
okay now you get a defense on the field
now you get situations and the way they
run practice
they don't just run plays up there
they're running situation after
situation okay backed up
sudden change third downs red zone goal
line this is
the game is made up of all these tiny
little situations and he became a master
of them
and now he's got this rolodex in his
head of playing against one of the best
defenses that can take the ball away
from you like that
and boom now i know what to do when the
game's on and they and they eased them
into it remember when um
oh my god how am i blanking on the
coaches charlie weiss charlie weiss was
running
two back you know drop back go look at
his first super bowl win he hit
one big pass on a deep cross to
branch or somebody everything else was a
check down to kevin's fault
everything else the ball didn't travel
over six yards
so i'm not saying that's easy that's
hard
that's really hard to do but he did it
and then he
he got that confidence and it was like
oh i can do this now let me try and fit
a ball in oh okay maybe that didn't work
okay let me fit a ball in here got it
boom i know i can do that i remember
this situation from practice blah blah
blah
and he just became a master and he's you
know he's got to be part cyborg other
than the one day he had a couple too
many beers right
like this guy's just incredible so
um he just became a master of those
situations and he had the time to
develop
in the right place tell us what you're
doing with uh sleep number the sleep
30 challenge so basically it's from june
14th
to july 11th 30 straight days trying to
compete with all the nfl legends
is that cool or what dan they call you
an nfl legend as soon as you retire
whether your career was legendary or not
there could have been legendary moments
that's awesome
are you calling yourself a legend well
as long as tracy perlman at the nfl says
i'm a legend then
fine i'll take the label yeah but um
basically it's 30 straight days i'm
competing with other nfl legends
you plug in your sleep number bed to
your app you get it all configurated and
then
essentially it'll track all your sleep
hits you with data points on restless
sleep when you're getting into rem sleep
all that kind of stuff
uh the only issue for me and i'm not
making any excuses because i'm a
competitor and i want to win this thing
but i got this child okay dan he's he's
four and a half he'll be five in
november
and he'll come in at any hour of the
night and i just see it on my data
points just a big spike
of restless sleep because there's
movement in the bed all right
and this guy will come in with whole
cans in the middle of the night
and just boom hulk smash so and wake
that up but
on the nights he doesn't do that i get a
a full you know restful sleep the
the full eight hours uh but the idea
behind this challenge is
during the four weeks they break it up
into you know a couple different
coaching points more or less that we
learn this in the nfl later in my career
but things to avoid before you go to bed
uh blue light from your cell phone
computer or tv
um you know making sure instead of doing
stuff like that let's read a book let's
you know do a little sudoku
dim the lights a little bit have a nice
cool uh
uh dark environment to sleep in and
really keep the bed you know for
sleeping type thing so
it's um it's great information and it
really does help me recharge and the
next day i gotta go
gotta go be super dad so uh and and you
know from raising kids kids don't care
what time you went to bed or how much
sleep you got they're ready to rock the
next day so i gotta be ready as well
it's great to talk to you again and uh
thanks for joining us
and uh good luck with sleep number yes
sir thank you hi buddy that's mark
sanchez former nfl quarterback
usc quarterback